the first thing I'd like to say is you
need to rely on those skills that you
already have as a parent many of the
skills that we have as teachers require
the same kinds of skills that we use as
parents working with our children
so rely on those skills that you already
have as a parents to lead and to guide
your children in their understanding
another thing I would say to you is
working with your children at home
provides a wonderful opportunity to
provide in an educative experience not
just in what they know and understand
and what they'll hear the knowledge that
will acquire but you also have a
wonderful opportunity to form their
character with children working at home
they're working on these academic skills
they're acquiring a character virtues as
well one that jumps to my mind
is is that the virtue of temperance or
self-control or self-discipline working
at home oftentimes requires those kinds
of things so it really is an opportunity
for children to continue their education
and to develop the skills that they're
learning at school the last thing I'll
say just in general is to relax you can
do this you're not going to ruin your
child in terms of education and in in
terms of schooling just relax take a
long term view of their education
schooling is one part of their education
but it's not everything when it comes to
their education so so do your best keep
it simple provide for them what you can
and help them out today I'm just going
to give you a few tips recommendations
for helping your your child or your
children to learn at home
that will make the time more productive
more rewarding for you but especially
for your children so let's get started I
have my tips here up on the board that
should offer a little bit of advice for
you the first thing I'd like to point
out is location choose a location in
your home that will allow your child to
get the most out of their experience
what this typically means is that you
need to identify a location in your home
that's well-lit a place similar to you
know the desk that they might use at
school so a kitchen table a dining room
table a desk in a room would be would be
a good idea
make sure it's well-lit as I said but
more importantly and most importantly is
make sure it's free of any kind of a
distraction now when when we're thinking
about describe any kind of a distraction
we often think about things like the
television being on or videos on a
computer playing or some kind of music
playing in the background or something
like that
and that's absolutely the case be
mindful of that and be careful that you
haven't created your your a study
location in a place that's that's are
distracting in those ways but also be
careful about conversations
conversations that you have with your
other children conversation between
between our spouses or telephone
conversations those can be really
distracting as well so create that space
created one that's free about any kind
of a distraction so that students can
concentrate on the work that they have
before them the next thing is to create
a schedule it's a very good idea to
schedule out the school day that would
be similar to what a child would
experience at school make sure that you
line things
with with that times if students I get
through a particular subject at a
particular time allow them to move on to
to the next thing again this will teach
them you know the value of working hard
and accomplishing you know their tasks
so that they can move on to other things
now in creating a schedule I highly
recommend that you start with the
subjects that are most challenging for
your child oftentimes early in the
morning after waking up and having a
breakfast and having a little bit of
time to wake up
I'm children are often fresh in the
morning and they're able to tackle those
things that are most challenging the
longer you wait in the day as you wait a
little bit longer their energy wears out
they get tired and so again tackle those
those subjects those areas that are most
challenging for that particular child it
could be math it could be reading it
could be language could be any of those
just make sure that you try to tackle
those things at the beginning another
thing that I want to point out in terms
of a schedule is make sure that you
provide breaks for your child even high
school students need breaks I would
recommend at least a 5 to 10 minutes of
a break per hour and that goes all the
way up to high school and as you go
lower I'm you're gonna want to do more
breaks and more frequent breaks the idea
is this if children are given the time
to step back and just and to stand up
and to step away from their work and
rejuvenate when they come come back to
their work they'll be more refreshed and
able to tackle everything that they need
to tackle and what you'll discover is if
you give those breaks periodically even
if they say I'm not ready for a break
have them stand up stretch whatever
because when they get back to their work
they'll they'll be much more able to
able to focus on what is what it is they
have to do
after that item number three is
questions ask questions ask lots of
questions throughout the day when you're
at lunch when you're at dinnertime when
you're taking a break ask a question
even if you don't know the answer ask
them - to talk about what was the most
interesting thing that you read in your
history last hour um what was the most
important thing that you think and don't
be afraid to say if if you ask a
question and your child says I don't
know don't be afraid to say ah I don't
know either
be willing to say let's go and let's all
find out together what that answer is or
if you don't have time to go and look up
the answer ask your child to - go and I
find the answer and then come back and
tell you what they think it is number
four on my list here is siblings it's a
good idea to get older siblings involved
if there are older siblings in the
household call on them ask them invite
them to participate in the education of
a particular child as long as those old
older siblings are taking care of their
own work you can invite them in ask them
to help my younger sibling it's a good
idea for a lot of reasons if you're
trying to explain something to your
child and you know you're not able to do
it well maybe another child can come in
and look at it through more childlike
eyes and try to explain it to a younger
a younger member of the family all right
the next item on the list is resources
explore other resources beyond the
curriculum that is provided by the
school there's a lot of things out there
online and of course you need to be
careful as you look at those you need to
look at those and review them before
your child is able to see them
no but explore those and you
use those to great effect use the
program that your school has provided
whether that's an online platform or not
use those to the extent that the school
is asking you to use those but don't be
afraid to go beyond those one caution is
that this is not the time to learn
something complicated online make sure
that if you're going to use it with your
children that you have a relatively good
understanding about how that resource
works and that you can use it
proficiently because if in doubt if you
don't know it really well I would highly
recommend that you put it off to the
side because there there are very few
things that are as good as a good book
in a paper and in a pencil so you know
don't be distracted don't be enticed you
know by a particular program that you
don't know very well and that it's
actually gonna take you time to learn
and it's going to take you time to
explain to your child use what you
already use to the greatest effect and
last but not least is read
if in doubt read read read read if
you're not comfortable with any other
you know kinds of technology and you
want to supplement the firt your first
option should be a good book look for
books make books available to your
children provide them with access to
great books depending on the age you
want your child to be reading aloud in
fact this is a great way to get actually
family members involved with one another
in terms of the education is have a
younger child read aloud to an older
child and read aloud to your own
children do it in pairs do it as a small
group or do it as an entire family
reading aloud is
a lost art and I would love to see that
recaptured and in one of the places
where we can see this happening again in
America is in the home so read aloud
make I'm reading a part a large part of
the academic day in conclusion I'll just
say this you're going to be able to do a
good job just trusting your instincts
rely on your common sense most likely
the skills that you've already acquired
as a parent are the skills that you're
going to need in order to provide a
quality education for your children